but Percy is the founder of the world's
first counter extremism think-tank
William international Majid Nawaz how
you doing
always great to see you I mean that I I
need you here more sir I really do how
often do you get to the United States
not enough right
I'd like to come ball hug too if I'm not
back from the country I know it it's
amazing well I mean there's so many
things I could talk to you about but
you're such a great writer I'm just
going to quote you on some of these
things are you going to quote me back -
I'm gonna quote you back to yourself
like I love you that you talk about the
the Voldemort effect and I don't even
read Harry Potter that's a book for
children I understand yeah so you tell
me I know what it is but tell me what is
the Voldemort effect well we see those
who are familiar with Harry Potter we'll
know the bad guy in these novels is
somebody called Baltimore and you
actually pronounce it correctly that the
T at the end is silent and the work that
the people
look the people of Harry Potter world
are so petrified of this enemy that they
are unable to name him and so for the
duration of these six books they refer
to him as he who must not be named now
of course it takes yes here you must
open it right you see what I'm going to
do see where you so it takes a little
child to say actually this person is
called Baltimore his real name is Tom
Riddle and I use that the Baltimore
effect to speak to our inability to name
and shame and isolate Islamist extremism
from the mainstream Muslim community
right and you are you have almost unique
credibility on this issue because twenty
years ago you were exactly who the
British authorities were looking for
when they talked about people who were
involved in possibly terrorist
activities after the Bosnia genocide in
Europe and facing some severe domestic
racism at home violent racism and
harassment from the police authorities
as well I went through a process of
recruitment some ideological recruiters
from a group known as his battalion
recruited me and I spent the better part
the next decade my teenage years up
until 24 proselytizing for a global
Caliphate and I ended up as a political
prisoner in Egypt where I was sentenced
to five years for membership of a banned
organization now I must caveat the group
that I used to belong to remains legal
in America and across Europe because we
didn't preach violence that we did lay
the ideological foundations for what has
now become known as a Caliphate okay
so that's your background I'm glad you
spell that out let me throw another
quote of yours back at you the poverty
of expectation now I know you're being
sued are you suing the Southern Poverty
Law Center for calling you it's funny
you're fighting extremists but they're
calling you the extremists well I wanted
to make this announcement here on on
your show I've decided that I'm sick to
death of well-meaning and I'm sorry to
bring identity politics into it but it's
relevant because of what I'm about to
say there's a bunch of well-meaning
white men sitting in sweet Alabama who
have decided serious the Southern
Poverty Law yeah the Southern Poverty
Law Center will normally go after like
the cool eight plan they were created to
defend people like me right you know
defend people like me
right right people like the KKK against
the people that were chasing me bro 15
years old with machetes and hammers and
stabbing me and my friends and and
they've decided to list me along with a
on Hirsi Ali a Somali refugee X Muslim a
liberal thinker as anti Muslim
extremists and I think you know I'm sick
and tired of a lot of the well-meaning
because you know the road to hell is
paved with good intentions well-meaning
liberal and left-wing usually white men
who decide that that I am saying the
what they don't agree with don't allow
for me to say about my own community my
own religious heritage and as a result
of listed me as a as an anti Muslim
extremist I'm gonna I'm going to take
them to court for defamation I don't I
don't think these lists and your crowd
funding it I will be yeah I will be
quite like to be part of a crowd thank
you sir absolutely yeah and I invite you
to also be part of that round I mean
it's just insane again you have almost
unique credibility on this issue well
the funny thing is built I've memorized
half of the Koran I'm a Muslim
I'm born and raised Muslim - Muslim
family I learnt classical Arabic it
spent time in prison as a political
prisoner fighting for what I then
thought was my religion I've changed my
views as to the interpretation of my
religion and along come these people in
sweet Alabama and decide the right I
don't have the right to speak about my
own heritage and critique it from within
and went it and when did criticism of a
religion equal bigotry well yeah I mean
look it we my brilliant Sarah these are
the same guys who arrogate to themselves
the right to speak out against the Bible
Belt right so the Southern Poverty Law
Center is quite vocal against family
planning you know the sort of surah
Gaddy abortionist movement quite vocal
against Christian fundamentalist in fact
they've listed some Christian
conservative groups on their hate lists
as well so they arrogate to themselves
the right to criticize their own Bible
Belt but don't want me to criticize
al-quran belt within my own
communion and it's it's this hypocrisy
that I call is a bigotry of low
expectations right low expectation yeah
right to people who are called bigots I
mean I have been called that you have
been called that I mean I hope they
accepted more from you well on the day
yeah but we're saying very much the same
thing yeah but poverty of expectations I
always say you know if if something that
would not be accepted here you don't
make a stir about overseas isn't that
the poverty of expectations in your term
that is like like Pakistan last year but
passed a law that was a wife-beating
guide yeah not not a law against
wife-beating a guide of how to and now
if they did that in Kentucky that
example but I love you too but right if
we would not accept it here but we don't
raise a stir about it there isn't that
what you're talking about absolutely
that's the bigotry of low expectations
when the same the same causes that they
fight for with in America are somehow
deemed illegitimate for people like me
to fight for within our own communities
the Quran specifies father reborn a
passage that talking about husband's
beating their wives this is something we
speak about regularly within our
communities that we've got to reform our
approach to this scripture and that
begins talking about the Baltimore
effect by acknowledging the problem
exists now if those vulnerable voices
within Muslim communities you know who
else lists heretics who are deemed to be
speaking against the accepted custom
within Muslim communities the jihadists
we know what happens when you list
heretics among Muslims in this way they
end up dead and it's no coincidence that
you take the examples of this in
Bangladesh in 2013 jihadis listed 84
Muslims as you know persona non-grata
within three years ten of them were
assassinated ayaan Hirsi Ali who's on
this list the last time her name
appeared on the list is when Theo van
Gogh the film director that she was
working with in the Netherlands was
murdered by a jihadist and they pinned a
list on his body with a dagger ion was
named on that as a next person they were
targeting hope not hater a uk-based
organization in 2013 produced a similar
hate list
our cider Guard was listed on that he
was subjected later to assassination
attempt so when I'm speaking in this way
and a bunch of well behaved well now I'm
just saying these guys are very brave
they are endemic Muslim reformers you're
getting it from both sides yeah
absolutely but who's who do you fear
more what I grew up fear evil who would
actually kill you I I grew up in
Southern Poverty Law Center yeah are
being [ __ ] but they're not gonna
kill you Yeah right
one would hope not let's see how
successful this little season see what
happens well you mentioned ayaan Hirsi
Ali I mean she was before Congress the
other day and I have some of her
statements that she made she wrote
actually an op-ed in The New York Times
and she said when it comes to the pay
gap bortion access and workplace
discrimination progressives have much to
say but we're still waiting for a march
against honor killings child marriages
polygamy sex slavery or female genital
mutilation yeah she was calling out the
four Democratic women senators who would
not even bring her issue to the fore
when she was testifying before Congress
this is a real problem I'm clearly by my
accent somebody from the United Kingdom
and if we if we and we've done this with
polls I know you talked a lot about data
we we have surveys that look at Muslim
British Muslim attitudes to
homosexuality for example one was in The
Guardian newspaper left-wing newspaper
reported that 0% bill zero percent of
British Muslims said homosexuality is
morally acceptable zero and then a later
poll ICM came along and said okay let's
try this again hopefully we'll get a
better result this time yeah
if the statistic I drew Pearce was 52
percent of British Muslims said that
they would ban homosexuality you know
this is what we're dealing with and yet
at the same time you've got leftist
activists who are very concerned about
gay rights within white communities
we're dealing with there are gay Muslim
who need our help
there are feminist Muslims who need our
help liberal Muslims X Muslims you know
apostates right they have the right they
have the freedom to choose the religion
they want and the freedom from this
really I'm always so confused about
these are a little these are liberal
[Music]
liberal principles I'm the show last
week I mentioned what's going on in
Chechnya and the number of people said
to me this week what's going on in
Chechnya well this kind of a it's a
Muslim part of Russia
and there's kind of a program going on
and let me read what the lead the
spokesman for Chechnya leader said he
said if such people existed in Chechnya
meaning gay people if they existed
because you know and they don't even
exist law enforcement would not have to
worry about them as their own relatives
would have sent them to where they could
never return yeah and we're the problem
yeah you see and and here this is where
the link between these attitudes and
Isis throwing gays off the top of
buildings must be recognized when you
talk about hate speech right there's a
Southern Poverty Law Center listing
people that they deem are hate speakers
or anti-muslim extremes this is the
problem here this is the hate speech if
you if you have these attitudes towards
gays or women or X Muslims and you see
what Isis is doing to them that's the
link we need to be making Saudi Arabia
lists atheism as a terrors of the fence
not even or not right and so when Isis
seeks out heretics in the hills
sorcerers yeah and so these are the
sorts of links we've got to be making
and that's why the work I do is to
challenge these ideas try to at least
within Muslim communities but I know gay
people out there are saying well that's
Isis you know that the the most Muslims
are not Isis and of course most Muslims
are not yeah what I like about what you
do is you know you involve math math
matters size matters I think that's
something you kind the term regressive
left another great term I think they
somehow ignore this this fundamental
fact that you know it it matters how
much how big something is talk about how
how big what would the number who are
what you call jihadists people who are
actually violent versus Islamists right
that's another level of it versus just
conservative let me talk you through the
United Kingdom the last four months
we've had four terrorist attacks in four
months we began with the Westminister
attack then the Manchester attack
and then the London Bridge attack and
then the fourth one has just happened at
a mosque where an anti Muslim terrorists
attacked Muslims in the same way I see
stars with a van nine passengers down
we've had these four attacks but after
the first three which were the jihadist
ones people began holding the Prime
Minister to account why has nothing been
done how were we not able to stop these
terrorists and the security services
said we only have the capacity to
monitor 3,000 suspected jihadists at any
one given time they said we're at full
capacity now that would be worrying
enough bill then they went on they said
however though were at full capacity at
3,000 we really need to be monitoring
23,000 because that's how many out there
are out there in the universe and jihad
jihad it's people who actually want to
commit well ready to attack this is
reporting for our security services in
the United Kingdom right that's 23,000
that they wish they could monitor
because they need to be monitoring to
make sure they don't attack anyone so
around those 22,000 jihadists imagine
how many more will be ideological
bedfellows the Islamists how many right
so what is that well right so if we're
going to go by don't our people who are
not going to attack but when there is an
attack yeah I go yeah so let's give the
view let's give them the benefit that
out the majority of Islamists are not
jihadists so there'll be farm anymore
Islamists who are not jihadists around
them right so let's triple that number
okay let's say most of these people
aren't violent they are just
ideologically committed to the theocracy
and then you've got the hardcore violent
ones in the middle that's only out of a
population bill or four million Muslims
in the UK anyway now if these figures
don't indicate insurgency levels and
that's just in the United Kingdom and
that's for attacks in the last four
months if we're not in the middle of a
global jihadist insurgency I don't know
what is if that's not the case we rinse
in a serious crisis mode at the moment
across Europe and the figures are
telling this so we have to recognize the
problem before we can begin to deal with
it so what can we do to make people here
in this country because when you talk
about England it's not the same as
America no that is not the situation
here an American example Roblin with
Americans is they hear this and
Americans tend to only think in terms of
America yeah and they say well you know
the Muslims here that's not the
situation but again
we're talking about four or five million
Muslims out of a world population of
over a billion and a half yeah what what
can what can we do to get Americans on
the side of traditional liberalism yeah
well the first thing are you right by
the way American Muslims are more
liberal than the European Muslims that
we're talking of here but that doesn't
mean you're immune to problems of course
you've had attacks here you've got
radicalization as a growing issue that
everyone's worried about but also we've
got to remember that this last attack
the fourth one was by an anti Muslim
extremist against Muslims yeah and we
cannot understate the importance of
recognizing in Europe there has been a
genocide against Muslims in Bosnia
Europe also has a history of with Nazism
of entire societies going totalitarian
so when you ask how can we address this
we have to be aware of what I call the
triple threat and that is from the left
the the weather you know the regressive
left is a phrase we use for the cultural
relativist so you don't call out this
bigotry when it comes from brown people
on the right would be with the rising
population on the right and then from
the heavens above the theocrats the
Islamist theocrats and so we have to be
aware of this triple threat when dealing
with this as civil civil society but the
only true long-term solution will come
through civil society pushback and you
have a great history of this with the
American civil rights movement with gay
rights within one generation I mean when
I was 15 I I grew up on hip hop by the
way based here in LA that the whole
hip-hop scene that came from hood
goodness yeah he did I noticed by the
way you had I'm a I'm too old oh yeah
dice cube on your show just last week
well oh yeah I grew up on I will
sensitivity I don't go on to the next
thing but
if you'd come to me when I was 50 and
said to me imagine within your lifetime
you'll see you'll see an
african-american president and one of
the most prominent rappers will be white
and a conservative prime minister in the
United Kingdom will introduce gay
marriage equality I never would have
believed you but that's how much change
can occur within one generation Road so
we need a civil society movement that
has everybody standing together in
solidarity against all of these
bigotries against the you know the
populism coming from the right wing the
control totalitarianism coming from the
left wing um you've got you've got
leftist attackers now attacking
Republicans James Hodgkinson in the name
of leftist activism and he liked the
SPLC page on his Facebook you know
you've got these that the riot at
berkeley college you got charles murray
attacked at Middlebury College and a
Democrat professor was suffered
concussion because she had the audacity
to invite somebody that the leftist
didn't agree with see so we've got a
push back against all of this through a
civil society movement and I often say
though I say you don't have to be black
to challenge racism you don't have to be
gay to challenge homophobia or any don't
have to be Muslim to challenges in this
theocracy
I need you here more give your lives
thank you very much sir